بطبيعه الحال محمد السعوديه لديها الخبره
الكافيه للتعامل مع الازمات يعني تاريخ
كبير من خلال العمليات الاجلاء التي قد
وقع او حصلت في وقت السابق من اليمن الى
السعوديه واليوم نشاهد هذه هي السفينه
السادسه خمسه سفن عسكريه وهذه اول سفينه
اجراء ايضا نشاهد سفن اخرى قد تصل خلال
الساعات القادمه الى مقر الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه اليوم كم او عدد كبير من
الممثلين القطاعات الحكوميه يقومون
بالتسهيل وخدمه كافه الرعايه كما نشاهد
الان مدنيين وعسكريين وممثلي قطاعات
حكوميه يقومون بتلبيه رغبات والتسهيل على
كافه الرعايه النازلين او الواصلين الى
قاعده ملك فيصل البحريه كم كبير كما نشاهد
امامكم
في الصوره من القياده العسكريه لتوفير
ممرات امنه والتاكد من وصولهم ونزول هؤلاء
الرعايه بشكل سلس ومؤمن
واستقبالهم وتاكد من صحتهم كما نشاهد في
الامام يعني مركبات الاسعاف متواجده في
حال لا سمح الله وجود حاله صحيه تستدعي
التدخل ها هي مركبات الاسعاف التابع
للقوات البحريه ووزاره الصحه متواجد
التعامل مع الحالات ايضا كما يظهر امامكم
العسكات السعوديات يقومون بحمل الاطفال
والسيدات ومساعدتهم في الوصول الى حافلات
منذ رسوء هذه السفينه الضخمه والتعامل
بشكل انساني مع كافه الحالات اذ تم تدريب
هؤلاء العسكريات السعوديات والعسكر
السعوديين باعلى التدريبات وتاهيل بشكل
كبير جدا للتعامل مع مثل هذه الحالات
الانسانيه في ظل هذه الظروف الصعبه او
الانسانيه والماساويه نعرف نعلم انه جميع
هؤلاء الرعايه عاشوا معاناه كبيره في
الخرطوم او المراكز التابعه لها
مما يستدع ان يتم التعامل معهم بشكل خاص
جدا نقدر ناخد معاك لقاء عفوا نتعرف عليك
من وين من سوريا
ممكن اعرف ايش كان سبب تواجدك في السودان
بدرس كنت
خرجت الحمد لله على اخر لحظه يعني
مبروك التخرج بس كنت حابب اسالك ايش
المشاهد اللي انت عشتيها في السودان واكثر
الموقف اللي ما تنسينها يعني اثناء بدل
ازمه
[موسيقى]
ايش الضرب كان الساعه واحده في الليل فجاه
كنا نايمين
وبس صحينا على الاصوات وكلنا جمعنا في
غرفه واحده يعني من الخوف وكذا بس يعني
الحمد لله يعني ما صار علينا شيء بس كانت
يعني ماذى نفسي شويه يعني بس
السودان انا اصلا من سكان كنت انا من سكان
يعني بدرس عمليه الاجلاء اخذت منكم وقت
طويل يعني من الساعه 4:00 العصر
طيب لو سالتك اليوم عن الخدمات المقدمه
على ظهر السفينه والله صراحه ما قصروا
معانا السعوديين الله يطول في اعمارهم انا
اصلا مقيمه من هنا 20 25 سنه يعني تقريبا
انولدت هنا ففضل السعوديه على راسنا كبير
والله الله يسعدكم
ويديمكم بلد امن ومحفوظ ان شاء الله الحمد
لله على السلامه
يعني كما هي
بكل تاكيد مشاعر الامتنان والتقدير والفرح
هي المشاعر الطاغيه على كافه رعايا هذه
ثمان ساعات سلطان هي فاصله ما بين عدم
الامان الى الامان كما ساعاتي الرحله التي
استغرقت هذه السفينه ببطسودان وصولا الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
الجميع اتفق انه المشاعر اختلفت في ظرف
ثمانيه ساعات عنده وجودهم او تواجدهم في
بورت سودان كان هنالك معاناه وخوف وقلق
شديد من ان لا يستطيعوا اللجوء او الوصول
الى السفن الاجلاء السعوديه ولكن تعاملت
السفاره السعوديه في الخرطوم وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه وكافه القطاعات بشكل
ملفت وسريع جدا مع كافه الحالات وتم
اجلاؤهم عبر السفن البحريه وحتى عبر السفن
تجاريه نتحدث عن اكثر من 2030 مواطن اجنبي
حتى هذه اللحظه وصلوا الى السعوديه خلال
اليومين الماضي وحتى هذه اللحظه عبر
عمليات الاجلاء المستمره على مدار الساعه
انه تحدث ان القوات البحريه صخرت كافه
قواتها
وفرقطاتها والجهود والكوادر الامنيه
البشريه
لاستقبال هؤلاء الرعايه واجلائهم من بورت
السودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
حقيقه لمسنا تعاون وجهد كبير من قبل كافه
القيادات بمختلف الرتب العسكريه بدا من
الجنود حتى وصولا الى الانويه المتواجدين
في هذه المنطقه للتعامل مع هذه الحالات
بشكل انساني قبل ان يكون بشكل امني يعني
كما نشاهد عمليه الانزال لا تزال مستمره
من قبل عسكر السعوديين والعسكريات
السعوديه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والت قارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات